Khloe Kardashian is making it clear she
will not be the next Bachelorette
oh the 34 year old reality star who
recently split from boyfriend Tristan
Thompson took to Twitter on Saturday to
slam bachelor creator Mike Fleiss for
continuing to tease fans that Chloe may
become the bachelor franchise's next
star Mike started tweeting about Khloe
becoming the Bachelorette
shortly after headlines surfaced
claiming Tristan had cheated on her with
Kylie Jenner's best friend Jordan woods
tweeting I have already been in contact
with my dear friend Kris Jenner about
Khloe as the Bachelorette
stay tuned Chloe and her sister Kim did
not take to Mike using her name for
quotes clickbait Khloe wrote in parts
stop or you will be hearing from my
lawyers
how can sensitive to which Mike
responded with one of the things we look
for in choosing the Bachelorette is a
great sense of humor might be time to
look elsewhere
Kim tweeted photos of a text chain
between Khloe and Kris putting it all
officially to rest that read Kim are you
guys in talks with the batch curette
Kris no lol Khloe you I mean put some
respect on my names even though we have
you know our ups and our downs like we
still always have fun what do you live
without a little feuding with her
sisters
[Music]
[Applause]